a tout de suite l'est du caire bonjour
alors une manifestation qui touche à sa
fin absolument amira nous sommes tout
près ici de la place du châtelet à paris
après une marche de 10 km et bien ce
courtage est en train de se disperser
pour l'instant même si vous pouvez
peut-être entendre derrière moi il reste
des manifestants qui continuent de
scander leurs slogans ils sont toujours
vent debout contre l'extension du pass
sanitaire annoncé le 12 juillet par
emmanuel macron et ce d'autant plus
qu'il n'existe plus de recours
juridiques à la mise en application de
ce texte qui devrait donc entrer en
vigueur à partir de lundi en tout cas
pour une grande partie de ces
dispositions je vous propose d'écouter
quelques manifestants avec qui j'ai pu
parler au début de cette manifestation
puisqu'on nous dit que cela va être un
passe finalement qui va qui va être
temporaire je donne je pense rendez-vous
à un ou deux ans pour voir vraiment ce
qu'il veut en est fait et puis je pense
que voilà c'est vraiment forcer la main
aux gens sur des questions qui sont
vraiment très très intime parce que ça
touche à notre corps ça touche médical
etc
des infirmières qui dans moins d'un mois
vont être mises à pied rentrée chez elle
pas de salaire pour pour parce qu'elles
veulent passer un maximum
c'est vraiment vraiment ça c'est
totalement liberticide et de plus ils
essayent de quelque part il peut pas
mettre en place vers l'obligation
vaccinale au niveau des textes de lois
dont il contourne ça en incitant enfin
quand les français parce que vous les
consommez malheureusement ne va falloir
vous faire vacciner si non vous n'avez
pas un autre soi quand c'est totalement
scandaleux vous l'avais dit il ya eu
quatre appels à manifester à paris
aujourd'hui
ce cortège a été entouré par un très
fort dispositif de forces de l'ordre
ils étaient très mobilisées aujourd'hui
manifestants et bien maintenant il
espère que la mobilisation sera de plus
en plus forte pour pouvoir faire plier
le gouvernement sur ce point